guys I've bought a mystery box here from
YouTube I don't know what's inside of it
I'm not sure how many of these they've
sent out you've probably already seen
people unbox these but I haven't seen
anybody unbox I have no idea what's
inside of here so I just thought that I
would do like a little mystery unboxing
for you YouTube always sends out like
really cool things to some of their
creators take a picture of this so that
I could post it on the Internet oh my
post mates will be here in 3 minutes so
I don't think that there's anything I
need to cut or is there but we like to
always have a knife just in case if
you've already seen somebody unbox this
you guys can probably guess what's
inside of here I don't know but I'm
excited to find out congratulations on
an incredible year here's to many more
hashtag YouTube holiday gift I am not
good at checking my mail apparently I'm
not sure what the holiday is oh my
goodness this is actually freaking
fantastic it's a suitcase we're excited
to see what you create in 2019 we'll be
here watching liking and subscribing
from the sidelines the YouTube team
thank you guys
oh my gosh and there's a luggage tag so
great look at this oh my gosh there's
one thing that I go through a lot its
luggage I bet I could fit in this box
I'm just gonna
stuff all around my house is just like
falling from the ceiling now I have been
traveling with something this size but
it's one of the soft cases and I
traveled all my electronics in like a
suitcase like this the other day when I
was going through TSA I don't know the
TSA could see that I could see him
talking to himself but as my bag went
through he was like I said it look at
that eye that's exactly what he said
and then I was like laughing only
thinking that he was like making a joke
about it and it goes okay I think that
he just called me stupid he never even
looked up didn't look away from his
computer monitor he was just talking to
the computer telling my bag that it was
stupid and I thought to myself I was
like but sir that's my whole life in
that bag that is actually my entire life
is inside of that suitcase and it's kind
of crazy to think about everything that
I'm making right here right now like my
camera my computer I had my drone at all
my hard drives I had lenses it was
basically everything that I need it was
like a mobile studio in a suitcase maybe
it was stupid or maybe it's my life sir
look at this cute little tag they've got
my little avatar although it did
recently change avatar pictures its new
I want to keep this on here this ribbons
this is so smooth very smooth wide this
is like something serious double-sided
tape this is one of the gateways
suitcases - oh it's got the battery in
it you cannot check batteries inside of
your luggage that is something that is
fairly new so if you do have a battery
that is inside of your suitcase they
will not let you check it so if you do
have a battery pack inside of one of
your suitcases you do plan on checking
it take it out and bury it on
this is the perfect carry-on size oh
these are so nice oh my gosh I didn't
even see this what a little name is here
on the suitcase oh wow this is so great
there's just something about having your
name on something that is so cool
takes me back to like when I was little
my mom would like put my little name on
my lunchbox oh my god there's something
else in here there's more things in here
what what is this a gift is it something
I can eat oh my gosh they're postcards
this is so cool I get both stickers on
my suitcase now I get it
to customize my bag so what else is in
here I think this is probably the
charging cable directions so these are
just the charged with battery pack which
is great I like this bag this is
actually a very nice cord bag it's got a
little arrow on it I'm gonna put
stickers on here so thank you YouTube
and thank you guys well that's it I just
wanted to unbox this because it said
YouTube on it it looks so cool and my
name I can't wait to take those away
text travel adventure finally the
luggage tag is a super cool name I love
customized things Thank You YouTube and
thank you guys for watching if you guys
have any other suggestions for some
things that you would like me to make
here on my channel leave those in the
comments below and I'll see you in the
next video where are we gonna go oh my
phone is ringing hello are you here
[Music]